ja alles was mich so umtreibt haben wir
schon angesprochen der staat sollte uns
zu diensten sein nicht und beherrschen
es ist noch nicht so lange her hat die
andere hälfte von deutschland ich
hingestellt und hat gesagt wir sind das
volk ja und ich habe nicht das gefühl
dass nach der wahl die bemühen sich
unheimlich im wahlkampf um uns aber nach
der wahl machen die ihr ding sie geben
uns keine transparenz zum beispiel von
dem finanzminister würde ich erwarten
hier wir haben r steuern so und soviel
milliarden und zwar aus mehrwertsteuer
lohnsteuer gewerbesteuern und so weiter
stört das alles dann müssen wir 7500
millionen dazu verbindlichkeiten
aufnehmen und so weiter und so fort das
wissen wir nicht ja und der einzelne
bürger in seinem kleinen leben kämpft
mit diesem ganzen maßnahmen die uns der
staat aufbürdet und er kriegt da keine
erleichterung ich sag ja tankgutschein
brauchen wir nicht wir brauchen auch 20
euro für die kinder nicht und die alten
und die jungen und dieser
verschiebebahnhof mit dem sie sich
beschäftigen du kannst ganz einfach alle
die 25 verdient krankenschwestern
kriegen applaus auf dem balkon was ist
das für eine regierung wenn ich so mit
meinen mitarbeitern umgehen wird hätte
ich keine da wäre ich ein
ein-mann-unternehmen wie soll man so
schön sagt oder eine tussi unternehmen
ja ich muss wirklich anders um genügt
wenn der start so wenn ich so haushalten
wird wieder start und so managen und
werden durch die bank weg pleite ich
glaube sie kommen an vielen stellen
nicht zusammen sagen zum einen der
finanzminister muss muss transparent
sein also ich glaube transparenter als
in deutschland ein haus einen haushalt
aufstellen für ein jahr mit einnahmen
mit ausgaben hunderte von seiten kann
man gar nicht das heißt transparenz ist
vorhanden wir haben jetzt eine situation
dass wir aufgrund der hohen
inflationsrate da gibt es eine reihe von
gründen preisdruck
kleine krieg pandemie effekte eine
situation haben dass wir alle gesagt
haben wir müssen die bürger entlasten
und zwar möglichst mit verschiedenen
maßnahmen auf dass der grundfreibetrag
ist ob dass der arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag
ist ob das der tank rabatt ist ob das
das energie geld ist dass die
abschaffung der regional ist es haben
wollte mir ein kleid das sei erst haben
wir so vereinbart als erste hilfe
maßnahme und wir haben gesagt dass wir
im herbst bei dem sogenannten kalten
progression bericht wo genau darüber
diskutiert wird wie viel der staat von
dieser inflation durch
steuermehreinnahmen einnimmt über die
lohn preis
lohnentwicklung dass wir dann darüber
reden möchten dass wir an den tarif ran
gehen wollen dass wir gerade für
mittlere und niedrige einkommen in der
tat steuererleichterung ja
das haben wir so formuliert wir wollen
die schuldenbremse wieder einhalten für
das nächste jahr das hat der
bundeskanzler gesagt dass ein
bundesfinanzminister gesagt bei den
grünen ist noch der eine oder andere der
versucht das aufzuweichen aber dazu
stehen wir deswegen müssen wir glaube
ich unterscheiden zwischen dem was wir
jetzt gemacht haben wir einen
haushaltsentwurf vorgekommen befunden
von der alten regierung da haben wir die
nettokreditaufnahme also das was wir an
schulden aufnehmen in diesem jahr genau
auf dem niveau gelassen was die
koalition im letzten jahr cdu spd
vorgeschlagen hat im sommer wir haben
die einzelnen ausgabenblöcke ein
bisschen geändert wir haben spielräume
genutzt zum entlasten stichwort
grundfreibetrag stichwort abschaffung
eeg-umlage um den einzelnen zu entlasten
wir mussten einen zweistelligen
milliarden euro betrag mehr für corona
hilfen ausgeben und wir haben jetzt die
ukraine kriegt natürlich eine situation
gehabt dass wir noch mal drauf legen
mussten um den flüchtlingen zu helfen um
unterstützung zu geben um unternehmen
unterstützung zu geben und wir haben das
thema sondervermögen was wir ebenfalls
schon ist das natürlich alles unter aber
wir werden jetzt zum nächsten haushalt
werden wir zum nächsten also noch warten
die schuldenbremse einhalten und wir
werden da das ist
es ist richtig genau deswegen wird
deswegen daran kann man christian
deswegen kann man christian den anderen
weisen dann weiß ich dass die
schuldenbremse einhalten werden und dass
wir lasst uns spielräume dann
anschließend nutzen werden und wollen
als fdp zumindest ist die diskussion in
der ampel dass wir kleine und mittlere
einkommen weiter strukturen entlassen
müssen uns mal was dagegen seien die
einzelmaßnahmen die sind teilweise
sinnvoll was unsinnig was aber auf
keinen fall geht und da hat die fdp die
hand gereicht dass der staat weiter
aufgebläht wird im neuen haushalt haben
wir über 5.000 neue stellen die sich der
bund gönnt wir haben knapp 37
parlamentarische staatssekretäre so gab
noch nie so viele wir haben sogar im
bundesinnenministerium jetzt mehr leute
als vorher obwohl das heimat ministerium
die zuständigkeit fürs bauen abgegeben
hat das hat also der staat wird nach wie
vor aufgebläht es wird neue stellen
geschaffen ohne ende und das beißt sich
jetzt sehr mit dem anspruch an eine
solide haushaltsführung man hat er
praktisch ein eigenes parlament ist voll
von hauptberuflichen
regierungsmitarbeiter der druck
konservieren zu müssen kommt natürlich
jetzt genau durch die schuldenbremse ja
eben schon gesagt ja dann haben wir 1000
neue stellen wir müssen entsprechend
runter und dafür dafür werden wir werden
wir sorgen
das problem zu stellen aufwuchses ist in
der tat ein ärgerlicher das gebe ich
hierzu wir haben uns da vielleicht nicht
so durchsetzen können wie wir wollten
als fdp und
zusammenhalt der menschen letzten jahr
gewählt wir arbeiten daran dass mehr
werden je mehr desto
stärker können wir entsprechend die
positionen vertreten wir müssen
was den ställen körper angeht was die
beschäftigten angeht müssen wir dazu
kommen dass wir auf der einen seite wenn
wir neue aufgaben definieren die der
staat machen soll auf der anderen seite
auch dazu kommen zu definieren welche
aufgaben der staat nicht mehr machen
soll und vorstellen nicht mehr das wird
schwierig aber das wird nacheinander den
nächsten jahren nicht nur beim
aufgeblähten staat ist der staat
überhaupt noch genug dienstleister für
das volk auch für die wirtschaft nein
das glaube ich nicht und das problem ist
ja dass wir gerade in wichtigen dingen
wo für den staat heimlich bräuchten
nämlich genehmigungsverfahren
beschleunigen als beispiel wir haben so
riesige aufgaben und die uns wieder
gesetzt aber wir kriegen sie die
umgesetzt weil diese maßnahmen bis die
genehmigung da sind über jahre gehe
gerade im erneuerbaren energien ob
werden darf von photovoltaik sprechen
oder von von windrädern da werden sich
gutachten doppelt und dreifach gemacht
und das dauert halt über viele jahre und
da müsste der staat viel stärker angehen
und dann natürlich auch den unteren
ebenen viel stärker fördern dass wir
dieses egal wenn man viel besser
umsetzen können es wird auch geld zur
verfügung gestellt und dann sind die
leute aber einer und wissen eigentlich
gar nicht wie es richtig umgesetzt wird
da bräuchten wir richtige leute die es
in der praxis umsetzen aber das war sie
gerade 5000 stellen das ist sie in
berlin da kriegen wir in der basis im
land auf dem lande in der fläche
überhaupt nichts mit ja viel mehr fragen
haben sie schon mal in der freien
wirtschaft gearbeitet ja den zu lassen
rechtsanwalt zugelassen
das ist das was nicht mag eine
rechtsanwältin regulatorischen feuer
beruf
nicht
ja dieses land um mich um meine ich wenn
er unseren reihen gehabt hätte oder
sonst irgendwas aber kein
rechtsvertreter aber die also
rechtzeitig hat studiert habe sein nagel
gerissen
muss
aber ich bin dagegen im parlament sitzen
nur fast nur juristen welcher am
körpergewicht übergewicht beamten
juristen sind der unternehmer wie viele
andere es kann ja jeder auch in der
politik mit ein ist ja nicht ja ganz
ehrlich sagen warum ich nicht in die
politik einig es war schon mal in der
bild zeitung wie viele schüler merkel
verdient ich verdiene ja es geht mir ums
geld wird zu wenig bezahlt statt 5000
milliarden drittel nur anständig
essen können sie wirklich was können sie
finden doch in der freien wirtschaft
kein vorstand ja kein mann keine brauch
die 80.000 oder 200.000 verdienen die
verdienen millionen oder haben soll
phoenix kreis da können wir journalisten
uns nicht mitreden überhaupt muss man
erstmal ausklingt
politiker die diesen status ist das
größte unternehmen im land ist nichtig
und auch der kanzler nicht so lueg
verdient wenn ich lese dass manche
manche ard-intendanten harry blank
beispielsweise und deutlich mehr
verdienen das finde ich auch
unangemessen habe ich glaube generell
ist das problem im bundestag er ist viel
zu groß es gibt nach windhoek eine
parlamentsreform halb so viele würde
reichen und es müsste berät immer von
diversität und vielfalt jetzt müsst ihr
einfach die gesellschaft auch in ihren
berufen und ihren qualifikation stärker
abgebildet sein als auch mehr handwerker
unfall ist er zum dritten mal den
parteien unternehmen dies bringe aber
was ist zum ersten impuls rein ich hätte
gar kein problem werden nach drei
wahlperioden klar ist dass man wieder
rausgeht
da hat man drei ja man aber 33 weiteren
hat man richtig dampf gemacht und dann
weiß man aber man geht wie unseren alten
jugend amerika gibt es zwei perioden für
die sagen wir müssen erst mal unseren
wohlstand sichern in diesem land und
dann an die politiker auch mehr
verdienen